greetings from podcast Ville the Church
of what's happening now is brought to
you by 23andme now to December 25th the
23andme DNA kit are on sale 23andme
helps you understand what your DNA can
tell you about you and your family story
it's named for the 23 pairs of
chromosomes that make up your DNA our
23andme DNA kit is the perfect gift for
anyone or everyone that you love there's
never been a better way to give the gift
of genetic discovery to your parents
your siblings your aunt your
grandparents and everyone else on your
list so do this to me now to December
25th get a special discount on 23andme
kid order your DNA kit at 23andme comm
slash church that's 23andme dot-com
slash church again that's 23andme coms
last Church it's easy to do you're
simply spitting to provide it into a
tool provided to you and your 23andme
kit and you register your sample so the
twenty sort of personal 23andme account
and in a few weeks you received your
personal online reports so go to 23andme
dot-com slash Church right now to get a
discount number to the Church of what's
happening now is brought to you by out
it whether it's alpha brain shroom tech
whatever today they're gonna hold over
the cyber sale so get outta calm right
now I need to go with the Alpha brain
you want to get your memory [ __ ] back
you go with the shroom tech sport so you
get a little extra lung power or you
could go with the shroom tech immune
which you help you when you get on this
busy plane hugging these filthy [ __ ]
animals go to adam.com
Press Church BAM and get ten percent
delivered to your house kick this
[ __ ] mule leak finally finally I
question finally how are you sir
really good man honor to see you again
thank you all [ __ ] time it has been
man last time I was on the show with you
when everybody was two thousand five two
thousand when you huh
karate dude who wouldn't [ __ ] stop
bothering me for something is hey wanna
be my bodyguard I did more movie the guy
called me every week you know I'm a
karate bodyguard
every week he called me every week - one
- what is it I'm a bodyguard listen
potatoes oh it's mr. Powe Master PO out
of his [ __ ] mind yeah yeah oh yeah
[ __ ] mine he was crazy I don't know
it's the 70s was a [ __ ] up time in
early New York the Martin Luther King
people see once Martin Luther King died
that they needed somewhere to go so it
took them Bruce Lee like people turn to
Bruce Lee after them and unless he died
they were [ __ ] they walk around with
Chinese shoes I don't remember that [ __ ]
when you see black people chatter to him
you know like what the [ __ ] you doing
I thought you Abdul is nephew you read
this Paris like this especially there's
still some black dudes that I know dude
right now his kung-fu school he thinks
he's Charlie I don't [ __ ] with him he's
black me shiny I work with it you know
saying he gives me a lesson he teaches a
karate chop people the time to time
their neck that is so goddamn funny like
like black dudes are known for kind of
coming up with their own [ __ ] well does
he hate all the time like one of the
best jujitsu one of the best judo guys a
Walter was a special style there was a
guy at a Harlem a big thick Kentucky
Fried Chicken [ __ ] yo you don't
like dwaddie
yeah that would just draw people across
rooms in fact he has disciples and one
of them had a school here I don't know
what the name of the art is I'm not I'm
[ __ ] him I'm not trying to insult
anybody
Rogan will talk tell you about him he
was sick black dude that was just you
know straight out of [ __ ] the south
and he learned judo at an early age with
that [ __ ] you know strength of humble
dish and he was just body slamming
people up in Harlem I forget what his
name was and uh they they really there's
some brothers when I got locked up in
prison there was air there was twins two
black twins i thought they were chinese
kungfu dues every day knocking people
out doing [ __ ] dragons and [ __ ]
whatever I'm in there it's a good thing
and shot the Chinese ain't nobody
shooting them that's all they do now you
wake up into another poor black guy got
shot this guy every [ __ ] day with me
last thing it was the port door guy yeah
yeah the poor guy
yeah they're shooting they shot some
kind of mall I guess they thought he was
the it's gonna thought it was the better
guy because every day you're gonna cause
a [ __ ] war yeah you can't say this is
all accidents [ __ ] accident these
people they put them out there they
never dealt with it they have a hard
time dealing with white people they see
a black person they shoot a Mexican got
a bit and then right they don't shoot
Mexicans no I send them to a different
country they deport them oh yeah I mean
yeah they've been going around they
threw a bunch of stink bombs out of the
boy there's some stink bombs it's
madness [ __ ] crazy we're losing our
collective minds it's no one he's stuck
at the airport I love those dumb [ __ ]
yeah well I see him stuck in Chicago
Chicago's a disaster yes especially the
one the one like the one after October
you take your life in your own ass
yes every year boy goes to the back it's
like made you lead to when the guy goes
to the [ __ ] back every and I'll Hara
but the other Midway
Midway every Midway sabja new Airy one
of those Southwest flights with mediocre
traction there was going to the drink
yeah I don't give a [ __ ] Southwest no go
into a Bannister and give you a free
ticket you don't know me I don't get up
for hours I just sit there I don't know
nothing I love when they try to get you
like I don't worry about that we'll give
you free yeah the gas on the plane I
drop I'm like that Chinese guy from
United yeah yeah I've never heard from
that guy again no nothing I'm sure he
got bored on TV well he bought
TMZ yeah he bought off everybody he's
the guy that was in the cave with those
12 he was down a cave he's ready to pay
cash if you're willing to if you're
willing to embarrass yourself like that
on a plane you could make some good cash
cuz their whole thing is they're gonna
drag you off of that Oh with a [ __ ]
kid no more yeah yeah blood coming down
if you got to bleed you'd be like a
professional restless I myself with a
blade you know just come out bleeding
I'm coming for you American airline just
sitting on a gold mine yeah yeah
remember in the 70s they did at 20/20 a
hundred the rest of this cut themselves
with the razor oh yeah yeah how they put
it a piece of tape and they would cut
them and they cut themselves god forbid
on the land you cut yourself and
somebody puts it on camera that's it now
you're bleeding and they're dragging you
off a plane Oh on World News Tonight
with David vissa why buy Mega Millions
when there's that opportunity up here
hey because you are getting huge pay
getting paid but you got to be willing
to put yourself through that kind of
degradation I will we do that on our
regular life support I'm done my whole
life for no dog let me tell you
something one thing they teach is number
one is don't take that deal don't take
that day of that deal I just setting up
to Julian you'll think that's the best
deal you like yeah tell them no I can't
tell them no no no they offered me nine
years nine years the felony and I don't
know and they're [ __ ] in and that was
really good that was a good little
violent it was good to my attorney was
like it's a good deal he was a black
dude that was his grandmother was the
first black graduate from law school in
Boulder so he just hopped and played
along and they did whatever fun I did so
he comes to me one day goes they want to
give you nine years for kidnapping
kidnapping who which means that would
have done all for nine years what I did
was bailed out whenever you get in
trouble you pay that uh-huh
the victim disappears the victim
couldn't go up in front of it because
the victim had gotten a DUI and then
when he went to hospital he broke out
and he robbed the pharmacy at the
hospital he thought the liquid cocaine
so his credibility was gone right he had
nothing I could have held that in front
of
[ __ ] years so what my plan was
together since there was two [ __ ]
people they hit him with a public
defender the other biker and they hit me
with a court-appointed attorney because
this conflict of interest that's why he
went for him merely get the rest of that
way for me to get the public defender
first and then I got him a different one
they got to give me a good one out two
hundred an hour they you don't saying
people don't know that the triangle
always wait for them to get the public
defender you hold them off you waiting
for the Iranian this is educational just
hold them off the Iranian who's this is
this Y on PBS you right now this leave
amazing t-top would be the shaking that
radiant the Iranian he's gonna call you
so by the time they put you back in the
jail cell
yeah he gets a public defender now that
means I prefer the judge and they got to
give me a real [ __ ] attorney yeah for
200 an hour which I'm never gonna pay
the state pays for I take that dumb [ __ ]
and I wake him up a few months right and
then I fire him then the judge gives me
another 30 days to come up with a [ __ ]
return that's exactly what I did so I'm
play Blacula for about [ __ ] 90 days
then he came back when in the kiss he I
got arrested November 18th
so my [ __ ] went through the holidays
right sit in [ __ ] in court to like the
22nd i sat in County to my bail dropped
so I was already playing him like a
fiddle that come to me the DA came to me
a bunch of them I got information but
get me out you know I got tons I know
she shot Kennedy you just got to get me
out just get me out Nick and then nobody
got me out key but my bail dropped to
three thousand cash boom I got high and
then I played the game with the attorney
for two months yeah yeah yeah and to hit
me with the 99 yeah I told him I fired
him that took another two weeks in court
the victim snorting coke somewhere in
Tucson he's missing you follow me so I'm
just stalling for time right and then
I'm 30 to 60 days he has no attorney I
knew who I wanted but I didn't pay him I
just
talking from stallin so what do you
think week what can we do boom boom boom
boom boom and then I dropped it on him I
dropped a deposit he went to work on him
and he switched the [ __ ] violent to
nonviolent he hired the private
investors again looking for my past
there was no violence so they switched
that this guy was that badass which in
turn is why I'm here talking yeah I'd be
in a prison with a dress on right now
doing the midnight Wow
damn so you don't have to know how to
play the court system but that is some
goddamn to our historic the attorneys
you could always get a great attorney to
buy time a great attorney especially in
New York could buy time yes in the
course and keep the cop was a a real he
was a real cop and he's real dedicated
and he knows he's not stupid
he's I grew up as the interpreter I grew
up in a Cuban house that they did
numbers so I was always the interpreter
uh-huh
so let my favorite spoke English until
the cops came and nobody habla people no
hablo knocks a man on fire remember no
say yeah I mean yeah I mean Spanish
people so even we went to the attorney
my mother is still playing like I don't
know nothing
so we had this attorney call say I'm
DeLuca in Jersey City look him up he's a
[ __ ] Savage he's probably cutting
deals on people from the grave
presenting the [ __ ] man dino brotherz
is up in like a [ __ ] fire case he was
bad to the bone he always I show up with
suits you gotta bring to it three suits
and I was always the interpret and he
would've just you come into his office
Keith the cop maybe just I I don't keep
the copy being charged with two counts
of bookmaking and one a money launderer
here's the deal I know the DA's brother
on the case for two hundred thousand
I'll get you six months probation
oh yeah hundred fifty thousand I give
you three months in jail nine months
probation fought it out you know and he
would just give you a [ __ ] menu let
me know what you wanna do great yeah
yeah yeah you had a week or two
sigh what figure you were gonna pick
once your game is 200,000 he stalled it
the cops forgot where they put the
tickets evidence got stolen it was a
[ __ ] scam but what happened well I
thought it was supposed to be justice
it's a holy justice I don't but you know
it's like I'm watching narcos and they
they showing you this Mexican government
they're so corrupt Jesus Christ I lived
in a government in New York City which
the cops would call you and tell you
this I'm gonna bust you through you know
just a little bit of a couple
calculators that's it yeah yeah hold up
they arrested you they proclaim cosine
you and what a coincidence that in New
York City bookmaking used to be a
misdemeanor it's a felony over the
[ __ ] bridge Wow Wow isn't that
amazing
is a misdemeanor in New York City you
got arrested for bookmaking you're the
ticket yeah yeah
and if the cops take a thousand for me
you meet him at the bar they give you
five hundred back everybody's happy they
make the papers you make the papers
everybody's happy you know the same you
make the police blotter they make the
arrest
it's a [ __ ] system yeah I know I
don't know is it still like that in I
don't know about who you are New York
sitting it's I think they've really had
to clean up I can't imagine getting in
trouble like a place here yeah a place
here everybody straight lights but
everybody wants a Maserati yeah he wants
the [ __ ] BMW right make things happen
but I think if you have money you can
pro basically in any part of the country
you get the best attorney if you watch
the oj vs show as as the show is a great
show
well what you learn is if you have
enough money you hired three great
attorneys know each other alive yeah and
you put like it's like a great
basketball team and I'm not being racist
here I'm just saying the truth five
black guys you go crazy that's why
there's something's always wanting to
have Bob Cousy to slow the pace down you
got four [ __ ] savages in one little
Jew to run the show we're gonna get a
not guilty plea all those uses something
so great yeah they had Bill Russell and
this guy and that guy but there was that
little
dude running the show and calm everybody
down brother calm down you know I'm
saying brother's gonna be alright even
me nothing but yeah I think that the OJ
thing did kind of show that wow the
money yeah the money really does well
now boys and it's a high school any
sense of me putting the Dallas Cowboys
it's a high school team yeah yeah I get
three high-powered attorneys I got ten
million I could do whatever the [ __ ] I
want
yeah yeah three million deep you're
rolling if that was Tyrone Simpson and
he was up for murder and his white wife
and her delicious you wouldn't even have
been they were electrocuted them with
the jab that wouldn't even have been an
issue but oh my favor to that a whole
trial was a verdict at the end when they
acquitted him and Kardashian
Robert Kardashian is standing next to
him the whole lawyers they got OJ there
and the jury says we find the defendant
Orenthal James Simpson Simpson not
guilty and Kardashian Robert Kardashian
looks down and you see him on the video
looks down he looks over and and you
could read his face going but he's
[ __ ] guilty but he did this and and it
just goes to show you what a
high-powered expensive team of lawyers
can can do cuz that [ __ ] was so
guilty what a sloppy murder
you ever watch Forensic Files it's
amazing these people try to murder
someone and not get caught they do
things and forensics they find little
fibers and everything Oh J just went
there stabs him slits there through a
blood everywhere sloppy mess walks away
leaves footprint and they don't get it
they can't get him on it was the
sloppiest murder effect they missed two
key pieces of elements they miss
fingerprints on the gate it started
raining that night on his gate are they
a lot of people are never raining that
night
yeah I'm raining it out lately it was
like there was like a light drizzle and
they could only get a partial print and
there were some other blood you know but
they thought if it's lifted
and they played the race clay made it a
race day yeah yeah and they just you
know they just did beautiful stuff that
guy Barry Scheck did great work at ena
guy yeah he's read that's a guy you show
up it was amazing when things get David
he's the guy he went into business after
that I guess he's still in business of
get exonerating people that have been in
prison based on DNA evidence so he made
a whole career out of was doing that
he's great into his office it's 200 G's
oh yeah I just a walk in his office
think about it's 250 GS
just to talk to him for an hour agent
fan to let you know what he thinks you
gotta dig the trench in the back you
gotta dig up grandma's mother you what
is it gonna take for me not and he'll
break it down for you yeah yeah what's
it gonna take
it's all about of course I gotta get
three investigators I guess that's not
the way it was supposed to be it was
supposed to be like regardless of your
wealth or lack of it you're supposed to
be able to get a fair shake but you know
you're never gonna be able to hire those
high-powered guys and I don't even think
it's the high-power guy it's who they
know and who've they've paid and and it
could you could have a genius lawyer
that knows all the law but he's got no
connections so you're gonna get [ __ ]
listen man I did time and I have tons of
conversations along the way you know we
sit around and we goof when we have a
good time but those people don't stand a
chance
keep the cop you know it you know if a
white kid gets arrested for possession
and the black he gets possession arrest
of possession he's from a [ __ ]
social-economic [ __ ] hellhole he has
no money for an attorney he gets a
public defender yeah who has a caseload
of 190 people who doesn't even know the
kid's name he doesn't even know the kids
case yeah yeah he gets to court that
morning and he reads the docket that's
the truth I've spoken to us oh
absolutely yeah and what it feels like
to have an attorney had to go out I'm
still doing time but I could have been
19 years instead of four yeah if
that's a big difference that's a good
attorney somebody who looks at unison
listen like I went and met with the law
professor at the University of Colorado
in Boulder he was a Spanish to it he was
referred to me by Sam DeLuca this when I
came out I knew my plan already I had
grown up in that world so I knew the
stall
I knew the store method of [ __ ]
stalling the whole system you know it's
really funny I was telling somebody the
story the other day I got arrested in
November of 87 but in July of 85 I moved
back to Boulder before I moved back to
Melissa just to let you people know the
level of corruption that there is in
this country in 1985 there was a bank
and when they made a bank a card for
Anthony comeon they made two cards hmm
one went to the bank and one went to a
guy named Lee up in the Bronx you'd call
your accountant that guy found out who
was and they did that all the time and
it was a huge thing in New York at the
time you remember keep the cop when if
there's under $50 I didn't have to call
it in under $50 yeah so we go to a
Chinese restaurant
yeah and 21 for lunch they would just
put the collar thing and roll it and
give it to you inside nobody's going to
look through a book of stolen cards that
the letters of this [ __ ] big yeah
back in the old days that's what they
were they made it hard yeah yeah like
even if you look suspicious even if you
had the ID for the guy on the card there
was one out of 50 people that would
break the credit card book after the
week yeah and look through the numbers
and go you Kannamma now match the number
here that ID that car stolen I call
police right I had to run out of the
[ __ ] restaurant but besides that you
know credit card was a big thing when I
went to San Francisco was traveler's
checks all right yeah I got they were
like stealing yeah well like stay just
as good as cash I got like you come to
Mingo I'm going on vacation we go we're
going to Peru for a week with the family
are you gonna come out of there you get
in Travelers Cheques yeah how much
travel check again a thousand i give me
to me say you stole them but i'll give
you when they give me a thousand I'll
give you back five ah and you make 500
and I made 500 what's the big deal I
would be all win I would do that all day
long
that's Alessi I don't even think like
that that's amazing
like that to me is is brilliant I do a
check that work that a Lord and Taylor
and and whatever you thirty [ __ ]
years ago
so I would bring her a car and go rerun
it for me and let me know and she'd let
me know what the amount was this is 1985
yeah yeah but to go back to this credit
card thing
so it's August of 85 it's June of 85 I
get a little lump sum money and I'm
living out in Boulder like a doctor you
know getting up at 1:00 don't watch
lifting weights walking around eating
and finally when I get for like 10 G's
there I gotta do something yes I called
my buddy son do some credit cards and I
go to the local mall I go suck an egg
war I mean I'm in there why and I'm
throwing the cards of the bushes and I'm
going back a week later and I'm using
them again this goes on all [ __ ] so
the whole month of July I'm going
through this mall the only mall and bold
oh no and I'm dropping shirts you should
see me gold chains okay [ __ ] pens go
pens ooh [ __ ] I'm like a surgeon and I'm
just buying VCRs I got a TV I got
everything
and one day I got a call and it's foot
lock and foot lock highs yet the more I
put an application when I first got into
town in June so I take the job in Foot
Locker and I'm causing havoc for a lot
I'm stealing sneakers some kid came and
if I kiss communion money an envelope
and while I was trying to sneak as I
clipped the whole family was crying it
was like a taja being guilty but by that
time I was done
I already have a call into the drug
dealers what was so one day this is your
answer to getting money like what day
this beautiful [ __ ] cop comes and eat
the cops what a detective
this uniformed cop comes in six foot
four built like a [ __ ] tree house
thinks he's [ __ ] Johnny Johnny
Johnson playing good cop bad cop the
detectives the good cop mr. Diaz can we
have a word with you I can help you
officers we've had a couple people in
the mall huh say that you're the guy
that used like a million dollars a
couple people have described you as the
guy and then the cops got called Indian
a custom some kids that won't got stolen
while the employees recognized you and
want you to go to our lineup but I got
no [ __ ] I just moved here from New
York it's my accent I'm clean they don't
run the computer at that time I had been
arrested one time for weed up on Harlan
78th Street he gave me six months
probation but if I didn't get in trouble
again in New York they ripped it up so
I'm good to go what do you want to do
well come down to the only tell man oh
yeah yeah I know my rights
well this one offered about ten days
came every day and then the parson
started coming by himself every day with
the [ __ ] uniform on - no we got your
clothes size pretty soon we're gonna get
an arrest warrant they might listen if
you had my clothes size you wouldn't be
here right now take a [ __ ] hike about
six days I had to go to New York like I
just had it he was bugging me that much
it worked and then one Sunday night they
came to my [ __ ] door and I came to
the door I go what's up Tarzan I just
want to let you know it we're giving you
an out on this you should turn yourself
in right now I don't even know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about
I got money in the bank why would I use
the [ __ ] credit card would you knock
it off with the credit I'll get the [ __ ]
outta here
anything less than that night I packed I
got the [ __ ] out there cuz I knew they
were on my tail it this [ __ ] cop
wasn't gonna stop huh
this [ __ ] yeah stop so two years
later I go back to Boulder and I got
arrested for doing 40 and the [ __ ]
2000 bag of weed on me the cop gives me
a break
and then I got arrested for something
else [ __ ] like IIIi didn't pay a
ticket so I knew that the police was in
my future
I knew the Maluku was not me but I was
running out fuel for years
and pretty soon as I got arrested for
kidnapping I turned myself in and who do
you think the detective was that [ __ ]
patrol cop that kept bugging me two
years ago with the credit card oh [ __ ]
so I'm trying to figure out what is this
[ __ ] gonna figure out who the [ __ ] I am
so we're in court together every time
we're in court I wouldn't even make eye
contact with him he hated me he hated
you again I turn myself in he hated me
the other guys cop name was Jimmy Cola
when they did that thing about the girl
they killed him old about a year ago on
CBS he was the white-haired cop
Jimmy Cola played the cool drug cop the
other guy played Johnny Tarzan so
finally me and Charlie Tarzan just
banged heads well I didn't really want
to bang head to them because I didn't
want to go hey yeah that's that guy guy
from a couple years ago so for the whole
year that I was out every time I go to
court for some reason he was there I
would say what is this [ __ ] gonna
figure out I'm the guy that he was
looking haha years ago never they
sentenced me the whole thing I came out
I'd see him I'd wave at me never better
never figured the [ __ ]
how the hell it must have been some
extenuating circumstances the kidnapping
thing how do you get into a kidnapping
[ __ ] [ __ ] drug grip oh okay yeah I
it's not like in the movies where it's
like ah you returned this person and
I'll give you this much money
that's an order or what yeah so it's
like kidnapping is moving somebody right
exactly what out their consent yeah yeah
that's the best when the girl goes oh he
pushed me and I went into the other room
god
like god dammit yeah yeah I she did I
know she fell in that floor don't be
lying to the cops yeah yeah legal
systems [ __ ] I can't stand it take you
you're talking about the stall technique
I always want [ __ ] to go fast like just
get it over with
and I think they bank on that you know
they want you to take a quick deal or
something like that I think I want you
to yeah yeah yeah but if you had if you
make them wait eventually they're gonna
be like we got tighter saw that was
lesson number one I was always taught as
a kid yeah I heard of all the old timers
talk don't take the first deal and just
thank Tommy go [ __ ] your mother's ass
I'm gonna take that deal and stick it
we're gonna [ __ ] let the taxpayers
pay for a variety right now the [ __ ]
interesting keep telling it to [ __ ]
da that go [ __ ] yourself yeah I want
this go [ __ ] you but whatever you come
back to that da you better have
something not like be a rat but you
better have something to twist his
opinion you just cannot go in there so I
was a letter writer I always tell people
to become a letter writer when you die
the church organizer you know Paula
automatically makes 250 obituary cards
that means that everybody knows 250
people uh-huh when the judge sees you
and he sees 200 letters he sees 250
[ __ ] voters per letter that's ways a
judge's decision always comes down to
that it's ways a DA's decision
especially if they have political
aspirations uh-huh they don't ever want
something like that held against them so
when I went when I got locked up I had
everybody haven't made contact write a
letter people aren't even in Jersey I
was just playing people write a sketch
I'm gonna write a letter he's a Catholic
you know he came to church every Sunday
yeah you get priests every letter is a
voter every letter is a voter whether
now or somewhere down the line I didn't
even think of that
it's [ __ ] crazy all the [ __ ]
loopholes you know no [ __ ] and it's
[ __ ] crazy when you get locked up
that's why we live in a system getting
locked up is I give the criminal
steroids because he comes out with a new
yeah he learned something when he's in
there that he didn't know before mm-hmm
now he has two ways to make a [ __ ]
living or three ways it's not
drug-dealing it's something else that's
why once you're in the system you get
caught listen and you'd never get out
get the [ __ ] out because every time you
get in the system you learn something
new somebody tells you a new [ __ ]
scam so it's kind of weird how the
system works
mm-hmm the system once you're in it they
want you to stay in it especially
today's system you know if you let's say
you get arrested in Seattle and you make
bail at ten in the morning and only chop
down midnight
why do you think why do you think Miss
America you don't even [ __ ] know you
just sitting there
why do you think because they let you
out of ten they don't get paid for the
day by the state ah that $48 they get
for that rotten oatmeal they give you
that [ __ ] salami sandwich they got
some [ __ ] steak them it's all about
the numbers the bomb filled so many
hours you know that I get business
businesses in this country of the
biggest thing is the halfway houses and
private prisons it's like this it's like
a [ __ ] license to steal
Wow but they just don't give you those
somebody just taps on your shoulder and
says hey you want to go partners with me
on a prison you get the license to steal
yeah those halfway houses they get the
property cheap then they get a land tax
they don't pay taxes they get a federal
[ __ ] government loan and a low
interest but they still pay the index
they still put it in victory over seven
people the [ __ ] one-bedroom how the
[ __ ] 400 piece that's 2,100 per
apartment it's a business people don't
know about this is what it is
you just don't know people you don't
think listen now the majority who or
none knows little oh right there's and
they don't deserve the people who are in
the system there are good people you
don't deserve to know about yeah there's
the pieces like [ __ ] like that no and
try to tell people not why not to get
arrested in [ __ ] like that it's it's
enlightening I don't mean to ask you
this if you don't want to discuss it how
is our
nor any noise I discuss anything Artie
yeah he was with I get these much
[ __ ] emotions about rehab I'm not in
rehab I'm doing a comedy show is in
rehab was he doing a fine time no that's
just it he I was with him first they let
me out for an hour
and now who let you up for [ __ ] hour
no one I didn't get it I don't know
either I I try to get info on him I care
about the guy we were you know everyone
loves our this is the first thing you
hear Oh Artie I love the guy I love him
he's and also funniest [ __ ]
you'll ever hear and it's true it's true
people love him it's super funny he's
one of the nicest guys but he's got his
problems he's got his demons and and
when when you go to rehab they don't let
you out this is when I don't let you out
to go to a bar not the phone they take
every details no TV so I don't know I
don't know what's going on I always hope
the best for him and hope he's doing
well and what have you but I've never
heard of anything like getting out of a
rehab - for an hour to do a show at a
place that serves alcohol and stuff it
just doesn't make sense you know it's
weird to be a comic that be 55 to think
of everything that I saw you could say
whatever the [ __ ] you want you know you
were involved some of the funniest radio
shows in history crazy I would laugh my
ass off
crazy shades you know Snerd when jimmy
first got on and off guys were raw at
the [ __ ] this and people [ __ ] in
churches and it was crazy sanity but
already on Stern yeah there's some
episodes that just a mind-boggling
it's not even radio yeah it's something
else you know and for Artie I think now
it's like having PTSD he survived that
Wow you survived what an interesting
take on like that you know Opie you know
yeah if you guys are talking down yeah
that's going on but you understand me
yeah yeah you put
that into that we all suffer from some
form of PTSD man that we don't even know
wait there's something you know I got
hit in the head when I was six at
Central Park in the lunchbox
changed my life forever I knew a girl
that hit her in the head she was built
like you nice and thin she got hit in
the head next you know she had two
triple D's rein her tits were bigger
than [ __ ] life you should've seen her
titties ahead she a little titties all
wife got clocked in the heads amazing
you know need to know the science behind
I know it's uh it's really weird with
the effects of fame due to you with the
effects of people giving you drugs I
told the story on here you know I did
[ __ ] coke like Arnie I know all those
spots yeah yeah back then that's why I
left New York Halle and I still can
control my emotions yeah in New York I
know that 2:00 in the morning I can look
at [ __ ] whatever the cop and the way
let's go buy a grenade you know New York
is the only city in the world that
offers you that yeah yeah at 4:00 in the
morning I'm looking and go we go got a
kilo and a shotgun and a grenade right
now up in Brooklyn and then there's open
you took yeah yeah they're there they're
open all night they wait for something
coming right those gun guy like me find
it no you swallow they're loaded outside
the carpet what it's like the hooker and
for the practical rights throw it on the
judge Reilly carpet nowadays if you look
into one of those open parking lots and
you saw a carpet rolled by and you smell
some in the air you just kept walking
you didn't play that yeah they were just
blocks upon blocks of just burnt out
bombed out buildings in New York that
you would only think we're in in Syria
now they're all built back up
everything's nice or they're gone but
yeah when you saw rolled-up carpet after
watching that movie and you saw a lot of
manure in New York City you just thought
oh there has to be a death that's what I
really had carpeting in the liver dead
hooker and adjusting guys we rather
which the outside there was no
technology then to get a want air out
they found the blonde there's somebody
shaved their [ __ ] about it was uh
it's crazy yeah there was times me my
friends out on Long Island we'd jump on
a train Long Island Railroad all hours
on a Friday or Saturday night and just
go into the city just to look around we
weren't going anywhere we weren't going
to a game or 57 okay so yeah remember oh
I remember those days and it wasn't we
walked around like it was an adventure
it was just you know it was danger it
was amazing down a down by the Javits
Center
there were nude women just walking
around
I just went to God the one night I swear
to my mother's face where that little
girl I have at the house it was early
show Thursday I take the [ __ ] rule
book back to the ferry and I stood
outside the ferry for five minutes I go
what was here when I was yeah I remember
what was here a thousand hooker it
hopless letting your finger room it's
crazy
disgusting you would hang out your
window they would let you squeeze that
day right and the four pins were four
black [ __ ] dudes in wheelchairs that
you thought they were retired but they
shoot you with a [ __ ] gonna be fire
hose and it was it had a beat try to
explain for the people at home that this
is no exaggeration yeah rich in a cop
was there a half of my whatever it's
[ __ ] names I know he's something but
I hate the cop bridging the cop maybe
let's just keep her name Bobby Bobby the
cop so he would remain anonymous yeah
still got his pension from the truce in
82 to 84 yeah would there be a half mile
worth of women out there to a mile of
women endless naked in the Sun aside
highway as you pulled up because we were
going back to Jersey so we go ninth
Avenue take a ride let's take a run
let's see what's going on okay we'll
come up to the cars and take their tits
out and you would suck them up ease on
that money while you're sucking the guys
so
from the home front is classic Aurora
cars
yeah both cars and all the cause would
be shaking baby like a dick and you
leave your car like a [ __ ] like look
at this street nobody would believe this
when I was in the police academy one
night when we were done and this was
early 90s we were carpool there was four
of us so we get we go we get beers you
know one of my one of my friends in the
car goes come on let's go see the
hookers we'll go over by a Port
Authority so we go down there or by
Javits they were driving around and we
turned and we turned right in and we'll
all the traffic like ah you know it's
just guys they'll make it and it was a
checkpoint right so here we are all [ __ ]
when you know you know you know so we
cook great shirts when the Academy come
pull up and the cop looks in the car and
he goes sorry Sarge come here these
rookies want to get their [ __ ]
come on so I started coming up in the
window he looks in he goes get the [ __ ]
out here word we just [ __ ] left home
what year was this that was 92 yeah bro
I was long yeah I came back in 93 and I
got a job working at a Nissan store on
57th and 11th maybe down bite but I know
insurance and they have a hotdog stand
on the corner yeah no insurance and I
don't know about then I'm talking about
10 years or now the 80s I remember these
crazy we would be headed back you know
when I started podcasting I started by
Rogen said start by Cashman and I didn't
know anything about anything like all of
us when we start a podcast on the
telling the story and one day I was
doing a podcast of Felicia Michaels and
she's sitting across from me she's got
the the spittoon thing like me so I
can't really see him so I was sitting hi
the pop filter for everyone looks like
I'm sick and tired the [ __ ] talking
nonsense so I told the story is how this
whole thing started to me
I had been in movies TV nothing ever
worked
I told the story about us going into the
city we went to a club I
name of the club doesn't matter and I
had a buddy who every time we went to
the city as soon as you picked him up as
soon as you got the car he would go he
would touch his dick and go oh I go for
a nice big circuit like that's how the
night oh but like Oh filet mignon can I
go for a nice dick second and oh one
hour every hour on the hour
Wow I go for a dick sucking so whatever
you went into the city with him you
could always count on him stopping and
getting his dick sucked yeah like it was
like automatic he was he was just giving
you a warning
like at some point tonight we're gonna
have to stop you know if you want to get
a [ __ ] out pay for you but it was
easy back then - they were everywhere
everywhere yeah so we pull up you know
and now this is and it was right around
the corner from Lincoln Tunnel so this
is walking distance a tunnel he must be
a mercedes-benz dealer there as you made
the turn and made the right turn into
Lincoln Tunnel there was a mercedes-benz
dealer I kept his lights on all night
and on that corner was a [ __ ] pretzel
guy but that guy he definitely died and
wrote a note before he died 30 years
selling pretzels sniffing that carbon
monoxide did not have a good ending
dialing [ __ ] raise yeah that guy woke
up one day it was like again sniffing
fumes smell an exhaust and dirty [ __ ]
this from brake pads he by blister a
pretzel and it tasted like a big boy so
we did we went around the corner and I
left how with Roger Pelle was the one
that was gonna get his dick sucked and
it was Al's car yeah so how did want to
go get a pretzel
so me and stinky and another guy we
walked over to get a pretzel we were
hungry get your dick sucked cuz I don't
want to send this corner I just don't
understand this quantity disgusting
there's a row of 20 cars and the women
are walking like The Walking Dead and my
lion oh yeah it was The Walking Dead
episode of walking then just wanted
walking across the street some of them
got beat up yeah
young everyone there [ __ ] just in
various states of undress and by that
time I was already done through all that
shad already going to I had already
walked down Broadway and they would make
you walk into strip clubs yeah yeah girl
would sit on your lap and try to work
you for a bottle of champagne but she
wanted 60 but before you did you felt
her up like a SAP you were 14 you dick
we get on you would feel her up till you
got dizzy does you're like 14 and then
she tell you it's you gotta buy me a
bottle of champagne
Oh sixteen dollars you like I ain't got
sixteen dollars get these [ __ ] young
kids out there but you have walk come on
your past you go into four different
squatching cover your pants I'm in the
kitchen right now with the mutant kid
they suck the dick or a kid it's making
out he's amazing be [ __ ] but you never
tell nobody that that that making out
with hookers didn't give you credibility
it does and now he's right now he's not
like making out with your cousins or
something like that like you know saying
I'm just saying that so we would go to
six or seven that like you said New York
was a [ __ ] and especially you were
from a suburb and went yeah cuz that's
what you did you went you heard about it
from your friends they were like oh yeah
you got to do this and the first time
you go it's just this you're you're
enough it's an adventure that like you
could die you always thought like this
we could die here and you always have
one night friend that bought weed to the
corner what terrible weed it was fake
what are you doing fake weed I would
tell you this cops around don't open the
weed take it down hey and by the time
you get to the corner you open up it was
tobacco with [ __ ] spit in it and you
went to get the guy yeah I was lost nice
long his name is Flaco there's no Flaco
[ __ ] hysterical
my buddy bought asked him one time and
they sold him a piece of paper with
coffee drip on it he came back I got
beat for 48 rule number one is don't buy
nothing on that [ __ ] toilet yeah I
wasn't there on Christmas don't buy
nothing don't buy nothing a guy that we
were in the city with he wasn't a buddy
of mine but it was a we were doing a gig
or some [ __ ]
he comes back he's like holy [ __ ] I just
got a VC offer fifty bucks and he's
holding this box and it's wrapped in
shrink wrap that might as well have been
bulletproof you couldn't peel this stuff
up and the label for this VCR was taken
from the Wiz ads the guy just cut
pictures of VCRs out put him on the Box
shrink-wrapped it and he couldn't open
it on the spot cuz the shrink-wrap
literally needed a knife so we're like
oh you open it open it
cuz we got to see what's in here it
ain't a [ __ ] VCR he opens he's like
no no the guy was he was all cool and
opens it up it's uh it was three bricks
three bricks with newspaper all around
it so jostle around well like what a
[ __ ] as who would who's this stupid
apparently a lot of people are they used
to have three-card Monte on the streets
remember those guys number three card
monte and they'd have the mark and then
the guy that worked it and then his
partner who would win there's someone
winning us I call my god the guy John is
like I can't believe this guy's winning
that oh and then you'd be like hey wait
I want to play and you got beat I was
listening
so I grew up on 205 West 88th Street I
lived there to the third grade I went to
PS 166 but my mother's cubed so we
always had a bar in Union City New
Jersey
my mom made the commute so I was always
a city kid that I'm never sitting there
my godmother my Santeria godmother and
the wrong way on though so I'm in
Santeria dude 148th Street so then we
moved to Jersey but I always as a kid my
godfather would always take me to 42nd
Street to watch the Love Bug and then we
started watching Charles Bronson movies
to valachi papers'
we always got a hot dog we walked to
Victor's café
that was my Oracle yeah that was my
[ __ ] turf as a kid so as I got older
like I wasn't scared to go into the city
like I already know how to get tickets
at the garden I know how to do all that
[ __ ] by the age of 10 or 11 Wow I love
the bead 12 ish dirtiness cuz Dom
especially out died when I was 15
blaster I remember going over there we
used to snort PCP okay we'd buy [ __ ]
they would call THC crystal wait at 12
12 13 13 like on Sundays like we need to
tell our mothers then we were going to a
karate tournament for some [ __ ] and
four or five of us we get to $10 bags
and we cut it up between the five of us
and snorted get on that last bus from
you the city the [ __ ] the city get
off at Port Authority and we cut a deal
all right you three [ __ ] morons you
go and I'm gonna take Lee with me
it won't beat you up at Port Authority
181st Street at five o'clock so you'd
walk to hate that blow me and Lee would
walk the tends to happen but at first we
would stay together for a little while
yeah what we've got all 40 we got off
Port Authority right there was peep peep
world oh yeah they have two people with
a peep show a lot of a people were
[ __ ] peep world was all oh yeah like
what office Oh nuts coffee and get the
ideas you get the fake New York City ID
there then you walked off the corner to
Broadway when you made that left to
Broadway this how lucky it is how good I
had it growing up across the street from
that Broadway like 30 yards away from
Broadway
there was a gyro place that was there
forever I grew up with those kids not in
New Jersey so whenever I was on 42nd
Street how long that for a gyro is my
high life for a minute or two the best
gyros in the world they were [ __ ]
Greek the Kazakh is bright the [ __ ]
tremendous tremendous Helen and her
brother our Metis and he worked at real
Greek yeah and we would go in there and
eat we all lose and then we would make
that left and he would come out where
the [ __ ] thing spins around and tells
you the news bulletin and that whole
street we were all on PCP oh that whole
street was banging it was one sad it was
a beautiful day to be alive
I'd be about 1:00 in the afternoon we
walk about 50 yards and there's a guy
playing three-card Monte and he had a
circle around but these people were
throwing
Travelers Cheques and they would have
the lookout and they would go cops and
they would blow the table up and the guy
would sit there go and I just lost 1,800
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was [ __ ]
brilliant how they did it but there's
one down there with this kid Dominick
Carlos Perez is still alive Dominic's
brothers Sabatino who's two years young
he was like nine we had him in the city
already with us and we're watching the
street card Monty and I thought could
put ten dollars down I lose and this
Dominic's fish out kid God rest his soul
looks at me he's like what do you ask me
yeah yeah having a [ __ ] scam didn't
you know it's all a scam all this is no
one wins and he as he's looking at me he
looks down can I see him and he's
quality oh and a [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] he's
saying all this [ __ ] to me I thought you
were more Street now oh no no this is a
[ __ ] scam and all of a sudden out of
the corner of his eye I see one of the
cards get him let's see him slowly get
hypnotized and he goes in this pocket
yeah [ __ ] ten Duyck you win this he
lost cuz the guy used to bend the cards
that's how they get you and even bend
the cards and show you the [ __ ] card
back and you still couldn't [ __ ] get
it I never forgot him call me an idiot
and also hit me yeah yeah
and now for like ten blocks we call to
each other you know who's the dumb [ __ ]
well you lost first I would have lost if
you want her lost if I wasn't standing
there [ __ ] you
that's how they do it man think I can
take that [ __ ] buzzing and trying to
make it back to 181st Street and then we
either walk the bridge and take the bus
before leave back to it you don't want
get them for it walk the bridge dog
three times I walked there [ __ ] break
that 93 they already knew that people
were coming over from Jersey yeah yeah
yeah buy drugs up in Washington Heights
so they were monitoring the cars but
they weren't monitoring the [ __ ]
savages like me I would walk over like I
own the joint
and I'm saying I would walk over walk
right over the bridge go right there
get my little half ounce of toot-toots
walk right back to broad
'we stop at the cuba to join two blocks
up from the hospital get myself a little
bowl each a with some rice and beans
fried bananas
I'd kill an hour then I'd walk back
they'd forget all about me who the [ __ ]
is this guy
forget about 12 year old kid walk know
this [ __ ] boy
I couldn't imagine life 93 when I was
doing comedy I was just gonna do comedy
that was worked selling cars in the city
and yeah I went back to do a short stint
doing comedy and that's why I lived in
four-link so instead of paying the $2
for the bus I just walked across the
[ __ ] bridge what did someone just say
you're funny [ __ ] I want you to
go do some comedy
yeah pretty much I used to wake up in
the morning go to Safeway or four leaves
steal a box of uh what's that [ __ ] women
used for yeast infections Monistat 7 I'd
steal 2 boxes from the Safeway walking
across the bridge and up in Washington
Heights
all those crazy [ __ ] Spaniards up
there they live with yeast infections
always sell it for the bodegas for half
price
it was like a scam every day brilliant
they brought aspirins and Houston you
saw a [ __ ] know I know junkies no you
saw the DiMarzio not that I didn't see
nothing some mark I knew it was a
professional junkie he lived off heroin
and I go how do you shoot everything it
was easy I still - Ted seven lights out
of the city he goes those [ __ ]
Spanish people they all got used to
define me and they got scheduled there
14 is [ __ ] so I heard a thunk it can you
[ __ ] yeah yeah - that says he's 93
whatever cures the yeast infection I
bring it over there I'd have a suit on
how much do you get freeze box like 40
bucks I'd have a sooner I was selling
cars on 11th Avenue 10th Avenue and
either Midtown Nissan I worked at like
two places and never worked in Adam asti
place I didn't like them I worked at the
Nissan store and the jeep store but on
those days I had no money I was a junkie
Oh Mike's I'm gonna take a shower
walk the Fort Lee I would have a
briefcase of everything I would put both
things in there some Anacin whatever
ride it like you're the salesman for
[ __ ] I would - fast walk over the
bridge yeah yeah
get get like 60 bucks to get the day
started and we'll take it from there how
would he breakfast like a doctor get a
bag of weed while I was like a gentleman
and then I go sell cars and then when I
ran on the money in the daytime at night
I was such a scumbag and going to cars
and take the quarters all the cars over
there for service I take all the tokens
ooh [ __ ] the next day I come back all my
tokens god before cameras so I'll be
there with the Sudan yeah this guy would
go some [ __ ] keep stealing the
tokens I Lacoste
I'm gonna find who the [ __ ] doesn't get
him fired every night it was immediate
corner at night I'd steal 20 tokens and
sell them at the boy I'd have a token
now you can't do that give me a blast of
coke I said I just saw recently a video
some guy working at a car dealership or
oh yeah and the cameras on him it's and
he's taking the money he's taking
changes few dollar bills or something
and then you see him look at the camera
and he he gives it this look and then
leans in closer to it and he's like oh
[ __ ] I'm I'm [ __ ] that's it you're done
they got you there's no film in there
you can't take it and you know they
break it they got your words somewhere
else yeah now you're on camera
everywhere like because you talk about
those old days and some of these little
scams and things that people work done
it's ancient history I am doing it my
stepfather was a very not paranoid
because of drugs he was very conscious
and over the years the education I got
from him was I he didn't talk in the
front of a phone really why do you got
to talk to you too much both side yeah
yeah he didn't talk to colos to glass
even in the 70s Wow because he know
about the parabolic my yeah yeah and the
vibrations off the glass if they got the
NFL he would tell me the feds Alexa
forget it he would smash it with a hey
yeah bring the likes of this house he
would smash a rat right in your house
all phone he would never have but it was
something wasn't to tell you huh about
like his code anyway who gives a [ __ ]
it's a different world now New York is
uh and that's why I say to you like when
I go to New York now
I is by landmarks those landmarks over
to every other gone yeah and I have been
shot when I go to my hometown now I have
a shock yeah like every time I go to my
hometown I [ __ ] it's like the first
24 hours is like how much more they
gonna build they figured it out I guess
they could make a lot more money that
way just plowing stuff over and change
in these neighborhoods over that's why
we're talking before it they could tell
when it's happened and they put it in
the coffee place and they put in a nice
little boutique and a Whole Foods and
things like that and then before you
know it you know there's a bunch of
hipsters in there and white dudes and
the the indigenous population it's
[ __ ] God and I don't know where they
go I read in an article a couple years
ago in The Boston Globe that a lot of
the new like luxury buildings they're
building are empty like people from
China have so much money that they buy
it as like oh I own this if I need money
I'll sell it like they'll never see
their apartments oh they don't want to
even rent it like actually go in there
and write yeah they just have it as part
of their portfolio how much are these
apartments over here like 25,000 3,000
for a one-bedroom I know in New York
that's not much but really that's a
relative Deanna is just a rancher just
put the but it goes all the way I mean
it guys it's it's grown yeah and the
days of I can't I don't want to buy a
house I can't afford to buy one lady's
house in this name but it's crazily no I
don't need a million dollar house you
know it's [ __ ] up a million dollar
house these days nothing is not it's not
like when you thought Oh a million
dollar house is gonna be a mansion
[ __ ] yard I don't have a day before
my house yeah now it's like a million
dollar house well you could fix it up I
got a million bucks I don't want to
fixer-upper for a million dollars I
wanna move in but you know times they
have changed all this [ __ ] the next year
or two the kids still young we could
read the read we adapt somewhere oh yeah
yeah I would love to stay in California
the question is where
you go yeah yeah there aren't many
places that are any better or worse or
you know because I look at New York and
go the second I can stop I need to
broadcast from midtown we get guests and
things like it it's New York City but
the second I'm done you think I'm
staying there pay those ridiculous
[ __ ] taxes sit on those ridiculous
laws that that infringe on every
constitutional right that you have I
want out of there but like you said
where do you go every every state it's
pretty much the same [ __ ] you you
get some a little better than others
with some of the laws and taxes and
things but for the most part you just
shelling out money you know when you
stop working you still have to pay money
like they still want taxes and stuff
it's like I'm done I retired if you
retire I want to just be done and live
out my life why do you still have to
keep Dolin money out to these
[ __ ] it's ludicrous man it's
it's [ __ ] how did we agree to any of
this [ __ ]
weren't they supposed to be representing
us when they go to Washington and then
they come back with well here's the new
law and you're like who who represented
me on that I wouldn't agree to that [ __ ]
I gotta pay money like insane amounts of
money even if I don't work anymore
[ __ ] them maybe you Belize right is
that what you wanna go keep buddies that
believe it's crazy ever thought about it
as a child
now you've never thought about it now as
an adult I look at it I just shake my
[ __ ] head and that's the cause for
freedom yeah that's a lot of fingers in
there but we're really playing a Vic
it's just him yes it's the same rig they
pay in Russia holy here it's hidden you
know thirty years ago this big wasn't
this exuberant no this big has grown and
it's growing every year and you know I
don't know nothing about humbling the
tax accountants I'm not H&R block's
nephew that's what they do they keep it
so complicated but my wife's the
candidate and when she shows me that
[ __ ] we're [ __ ] hard stuff it's it's
that stops my heart stop how did we
agree that I work you know I know I'm on
the road I gotta carry luggage you know
on the road the [ __ ] prices are the
superinten you go to a hole you know we
went to a hotel the Boston Red Sox will
play the Yankees all the hotels doubled
up and something rice oh boy is that you
know it's like you have no idea you know
the amount of tips you doll out you know
the volume that you need to do I can't
do anymore
mmm to really really really bite into
comedy I'm too old for it when I don't
wait to burn out I like to do the
podcast twice a week then to stand up
for a weekend then have a couple of
weekends off and yeah I'm one of those
guys relax it this really do it is to do
it every week and to do two theaters an
item whatever I don't have it at me I
don't want to be that guy that's not
what I signed up for and how about some
downtime just to [ __ ] recharge or
relax or enjoy yourself you can't even
do that now because you got to keep
pushing and pushing to pay that Vig that
you're talking about you don't want to
look at these houses in Woodland Hills
I'm not a [ __ ] idiot
and I know one thing I know what it is
to [ __ ] starve because I starve years
ago beans when I was married I didn't
know what vignette everybody you got to
keep your vague [ __ ] LoJack it's got
to stay low and every effort I Drive a
Subaru Richie great [ __ ] cards 260
for a month and I don't drive the same
Diego back from Boise you're not gonna
bang me on the fifty cents a mile I'm
not a [ __ ] uber driver so you never
say right right I mean I look at and
it's not being shrewd or cheap it's just
getting the most for your [ __ ]
dollars nobody's [ __ ] economy you
know it's a [ __ ] night man it's crazy
it really is and what happens when the
ticket stop selling I'm gonna happen
when the TV shows that's what you gotta
worry about it happened to your Vegas
still 12 G's a month mmm you know I can
borrow 1,200 keep the cop I can borrow
1212 down that's a tough
navara a tough one to borrow I hear you
man I come to you like a man I went from
having a rough month I need about ain't
about 264 my super you'll give it to me
with a smile that's if I come you say I
got a for 600 from my Porsche you know
Joey yes yes I saw the [ __ ] boys you
know I'm saying it's time to suck dick
so the port and there's just no
accountability to it either like like if
I was paying this amount of taxes and I
got this list of everything that was
being done and thought without buddy
asked already good what's my money going
for right but these [ __ ] are
all the most corrupt scumbag how the
[ __ ] is someone like Pelosi and and
Warren and and all of me Republicans how
do they go into a public service the
noble occupation of public service and
leave multi millionaires with the
greatest houses uh not anywhere near
their their constituency you know they
don't live in the areas that the people
they represent they live in these
amazing houses it's a how does that
happen how did you the person that was
supposed to go to Washington in lieu of
myself to represent me and tell the
upper echelon of government what I need
back where you live how did you end up
[ __ ] rich and I'm seeing you paying
you to go and tell them what I need it's
[ __ ] it's not the way it was supposed
to be and we just we eat it we sit there
and eat it because there's no recourse
what do we what he's supposed to do
revolt they'll throw you in [ __ ]
prison in a second you even start
talking about the fact that you're
dissatisfied with the government these
days and on social media and they'll
leave it throw your off or they'll call
you something a store a fold or whatever
it is but you have no recourse to go
after the government you think votes do
it the closest we got is Trump we voted
in a [ __ ] maniac and I love it
I couldn't be happier I wanted a monkey
wrench thrown into the work
and he's hilarious so at least I'm
getting my money's worth there but other
than that where do we go to say I don't
like the idea that this person's
supposed to be representing me is making
a fortune and we have to pay more and
more every year like you said how about
you done with work all that money you
made maybe things slowed down and now
you can't you have to still pay them I
paid you a fuckload when I was doing
really well now maybe things aren't
doing so well you're gonna cut me a
break
oh no they worsen above you oh it's
their word they are they're worse than
the mom you know it's so weird how I
grew up in Hudson County that's like the
second most corrupt town woof what I
left Hudson County in 83 I knew I didn't
like politics like I had already said to
myself why would somebody do it do a job
for 28 grand out of the kindness of
their heart but I gonna pull that uncle
Joey ah ah [ __ ] anthill beliefs
because they know there's something in
the back of course okay so if I saw that
at a micro level at a micro level think
of what it is mad at a macro level
there's that lady in Mississippi you put
the Confederate hat on and said they
should hang people and lynch people in
all this [ __ ] did you see all the people
that gave her money then once that money
back isn't it crazy so what do you do
with this money what are you doing all
these contributions you really use them
no you use half of them and you [ __ ]
cook the books and now you live like a
[ __ ] doctor you live Craven you know
I mean if you don't know this is an
American there's something wrong with
exist I am that they're really in there
for you yeah this is what you really
want to do it don't go for it but you're
a time sitting there watch listen I want
that 330i stop for my daughter goes to
karate or four but at 3:30 I don't give
a [ __ ] I want world news tonight just
see what they got to say it matter I
can't even wait till 6:30 I gotta watch
the 331 oh right I see a bunch of people
with red shirts jumping up and down like
what the [ __ ] is this
a bunch of [ __ ] [ __ ] jumping up and
down red sherry I thought they stood I
took this out cancer
Rubik's Cube son they landed in [ __ ]
Mars like I give a [ __ ] adapt olivine
I don't give a [ __ ] there's people in
the homeless out there there's people
starving I thought you clear Dave I tell
you your cue and hepatitis C a bunch of
white people jumping up and down only
white people give a [ __ ] about Mars
people don't give a [ __ ] about Mars
those dick log ones that are getting
[ __ ] gas ask them about Mars and they
don't care about Mars only [ __ ] white
people with purple shirts on a jumping
up and down high-fiving cuz the camera
landed in MA
yeah it took eight years I give a [ __ ]
really I noticed the astounding lack of
diversity in that room we're gonna
[ __ ] that one Porto Rican in there no
all right not one boiler Rican not one
black you know what NASA stands for
don't even let me tell you don't even
make me tell you what NASA stands for
[Laughter]
change the words around insane
NASA pricks and I don't want to say it
and AAA that's [ __ ] KK and [ __ ]
[ __ ] oh my god yeah people what the [ __ ]
is now they're all full of [ __ ] I sit
down I [ __ ] I don't like none of them
I've never liked none of them I'm like
the [ __ ] guy never trusted him on my
Tony Montana yeah ever trusted those
people and ever trust they're all evil
they all look for a [ __ ] there's an
underlying reason that's all all of them
get into that nobody takes the pressure
of the world for two hundred twenty five
thousand dollars a year now you can make
that selling cause yeah why would you
have to be you are the link above
everything all the blame of everything
everything that happens they blame you
to our hundred twenty-five thousand
dollars that's why you want to be the
most powerful man yeah yeah cuz you get
Secret Service protection for the next
time [ __ ] family no because there's
something on the back end is some and
even these other people the the
representatives the Congress senators
they all have an interest everything
they do when they get that war chest
they talk about all that we got
donations for our election then
they go to a union and they go we're
gonna make a contribution to the union
just make sure all you guys vote for me
and they put the the strong-armed on all
the union members to vote a certain way
because they got paid off it's it's it's
no different than the mob its mafia
tactics it's extortion it's bribery it's
all that [ __ ] but somehow when they do
it it's legal and it's the American Way
and it's our democracy at work I went to
the doctor the other day about a month
ago we're talking he looks on my [ __ ]
description list you know so what do you
want right now these days oh I gotta get
you off that I've got a push on some
Mouse hat okay I get home and give my
wife you know I gotta go to CVS I pick
the prescription of my wife goes what's
this one - doctor said nothing take side
of him whatever the [ __ ] blood
pressure take this one
she's what happened - I don't [ __ ]
know I don't know he doesn't what the do
I do it well my wife being white marry
that she does she gets online she
investigates it it's just a [ __ ] pill
it's just this [ __ ] pill then they
put chalk in it and she did the research
on it okay how did that get through how
did that get through it's election time
you go to Holland oh I'd say the board
is seven people vote you go to forum to
say there's more money if that comes
relative this can right past the FDA
passes it you know that's why you see
these prescriptions come out all at one
shot Sonova never again now there's one
if you [ __ ] suck dick a lot you wanna
suck em [ __ ] we got it for you
this will help you not get the hip
you'll get to half of it off with no spy
show a bunch of ya alligators yeah yeah
you show the transsexual do ya I take it
every day hey this one and make this
uptick how the [ __ ] do does that get
past
that's a 90 days camp
two years you're watching late night TV
did you take that pill to [ __ ] suck
like to cause now call us a suicide from
all of a sudden if your balls fell off
when I was a kid every [ __ ] I ate
tastes like every full time you fingered
a girl talcum powder was on your hand
like you figured somebody yeah captain
Pyle you figure Catholic girls top the
pile all of a sudden everybody's [ __ ]
right from top and pilot now it's not a
have your ovaries falling edge yeah yeah
they blame a lot of time that's the best
[ __ ] everybody can try it kept the
inside was like putting like a little
fall on the chicken it kept the inside I
kept it kept the outside fresh but the
inside had that one too it's fresh and
moisten it when you open up the little
prick me cable that's a top compartment
you know what in the seventies you had
that rule head boys oh yeah yeah combo
gyro yeah like a Venus flytrap like from
the 70s on the bush got smaller yeah
yeah yeah 79 78 with Julius Irving in
the ABA the big Bush made a comeback I
used to date a girl I had a bush that
came out from the sides Wow was the
sexiest thing ever that's crazy
the hair came out from the sides and it
was like long when it got wet she could
pet it like a little bit [ __ ] monkey
look at that kids whatever which is pet
day [ __ ] if this is a god they went
through a few stages they had the
landing strip and the Hitler mustache
little thing and then and then when it
went completely wood floor that like
freaks some people out but then now I
think the bushes make a little more of a
comeback I like something cause my god I
know where you are
that bald [ __ ] [ __ ] makes you feel
creepy it was looking out for a camera
we used to call him rattle
you know what the [ __ ] we is that we
used to play a game on the O nation it's
gotta look you guess what's in your
pants and we'd have a girl and she would
rub the phone on her [ __ ] and we'd have
to guess if it was a landing strip a
Hitler mustache or she was fully shaved
or and and you could hear like if we go
alright now go side to side you hear
like watch and you knew it was like a
landing strip because it was getting
that that staticky sound just for a
little split second like Morse code and
then if it was completely bald we called
it the Jean Monnet really just so rank
so offensive but but the JonBenet was
actually the loudest one because it had
nothing to patter I was just rubbing on
the skin so a lot of girls participated
though they liked that stuff that was
the old shock jacory of the old days
guys now it's not even but now who are
you gonna shock it on radio you first of
all I get sued the me to movement will
come after you and then the other thing
is you pick up your phone go ahead watch
videos you can see on there who's
shocking anyone on a microphone from a
radio station anymore
well I grew up in Boston and I forgive
me if I'm wrong but I remember having
this bumper sticker as a kid that said
whip him out Wednesday yeah Wow yeah
yeah we did the whip amount Wednesday
you put a sticker on your car and it was
if a girl saw it and felt so inclined
she would flash her tits at the guy with
the WoW sticker so they became they were
everywhere cuz guys thought you know if
there's a chance I could be in traffic
on the way home and see tits yeah that's
awesome so people were slapping these
Wow stickers all over the place and you
know we got some [ __ ] from that from the
state 'yes the Massachusetts state is
like this is a obviously a very
dangerous process we don't want people
showing it was you know it's [ __ ]
Boston right how many times you guys get
fined by the FCC well you the funny
thing of is about CBS Radio they never
got fined what they would do is litigate
with the FCC and pay a contribution so
that way their record was clean the
whole time and they said well we've
never paid an FCC fine but they would
make contributions so we had probably
three or four of those but complain
it's up the ass just every time we turn
around somebody would be writing you and
you just have to write a [ __ ] letter
to imagine having the gumption to get a
pen and paper
find out who where the FCC is right I
was very offended my dear sir and stamp
out to the mailbox just insanity a
mental patient letters mail for me at
the Comedy Store letters like I went
through your show the other you know the
song fine dude could you believe it and
I would go while
who the [ __ ] would go home some whose
wife is not suck yeah yeah that's the
only reason you would go home after your
comedy show right away dick you a
[ __ ] the comics up cuz they're either
extremely passionate about what they
write you about or their [ __ ] mental
patients and that's something that's
lost now in social media people now they
get on Twitter or Facebook or whatever
it is and they could just go
you suck or what you did sucked it and
we talked about the old days like Frank
Sinatra he could do a show Frank Sinatra
never opened the letter that said hey
Frank
you suck by some anonymous guy cuz the
guy would have to sit there find out
where was Frank planked what was his
publicist who do I write to what do I do
how do I get to Frank Sinatra nowadays
people have too much access to just tell
people they suck for no other [ __ ]
reason these people that have
accomplished nothing in their own lives
now have access to people that have done
pretty cool [ __ ] just to tell them that
you know they're [ __ ] they suck
they're ugly there's whatever the [ __ ]
it is I think people have a little too
much access now to other people great to
read when you post a video on YouTube
the comments the comments are ridiculous
writing is great to rewrite what people
say to you people look at first the
first year or two it doesn't cut you the
first two or three yeah and then after
that you have to think about this
situation right and think about your
situation a little bit from a different
logistic and go what I would never do
that
who would do that right you know what
your chances are me yelping
I'm a good deal how only Yelp and I will
read you ever I'm right now assumption
of my [ __ ] home ok yeah yeah I go
into your place that sucks I'm not gonna
tell nobody unless somebody goes to tell
me that I love that they're gonna go
weak and you're [ __ ] don't be playing
number two tell them not to go there
yeah yeah but nothing's gonna make me go
home win and report you and to the world
you're gonna tell the world that you
think that sucks you know what [ __ ]
you know [ __ ] up you [ __ ] up you
made a bad choice there was something
that was tremendous up the corner but
you chose that you knew it was good but
you chose there because you wanted to be
new and adventurous well your father
between my legs okay we do adventures
that went down the corner that's been
there for 80 years for a [ __ ] reason
you know it's gonna right I was telling
you about before that I love you to
death
I've always respected you the [ __ ]
voices and the [ __ ] that you would do
early on and all that but you have a
show and I tell you that it's 4:00 to
6:00 and you're not gonna catch me in
this city no it's not gonna happen and
did the annals on the city but it's so
weird how I just don't like straight
like say keep the company you're
watching me [ __ ] I I know I like the
idea of slowing down a bit like years
ago first doing the own a show and first
getting into radio I wanted to balls out
110 miles an hour
just whatever and you get to a point now
where it's kind of like I want to enjoy
myself a little more now I don't want to
have to work as hard in order to to play
you know and and I think it just goes it
goes with going through your 50s I
honestly think that like by the time you
get 50 you're not an old guy you're not
ready to [ __ ] cash it in but you know
what as you go through your 50s you kind
of want to [ __ ] chill a little more I
don't need as much danger in my life
before you know it was cool to kind of
go out as a younger guy and
and not get into trouble but potentially
get into trouble to skirt trouble a
little bit with your buddies and
everything that ain't me anymore like I
I can't be bothered I want to relax it's
amazing the things that don't even
bother asking yeah there's a thousand
things that ship sail right like you
wanna go to a Rams game no no no Giants
game billion [ __ ] I'm gonna pay $50 to
you [ __ ] Park its miserable
I paid $15 to go see the mix of Bernard
King yeah you know I paid fifteen fifty
for Pink Floyd the war the Nassau
Coliseum in 1980 yeah you want 400 for a
ticket no shame but 400 for taking on
you shame on you yeah shame on you you
know there's so many things that I am
over done like you hit a certain age for
me I think it was like 44 45 like I've
always been a little outside of the box
I've never really believed in what most
people believed in you know I got away
with murder for years so that whole fear
thing has been gone but something
happens once you realize that you don't
have much time left
oh the reality yeah you wake up you're
over the hump when you turn 50 nobody
comes in the room surprised oh my god
what does it feel like to be feels great
and then that you don't by yourself and
you like I'm 50 yeah yeah mmm there's no
turning back there if it's a time to
become religious it's today it's today
there's a time to really do what I want
to do which today yeah you're over that
long two hours in the 405 to come meet
in a seafood place for lunch you know
tell me on the [ __ ] phone right yeah
call me and tell me I'm not driving two
hours there's a two hours look I could
be sick listen to the Eagles opt-out
California hey guys [ __ ] dope
that's construction enjoying yourself
relaxing yeah yeah you know it's so
we're not you look
things and go nope ya know the knowledge
the wisdom like you already know you
just look at something and you already
see it's like watching Everybody Hates
Chris when he would look at something
and he think about assess it and you
don't have you don't even have like I've
been down this street already twice yeah
that's just it you use all your
experiences that you've had in your life
and you can assess something very
quickly now and directly no I just see
it coming a mile away
I brought that right back up and through
it I've seen it before and this is how
it plays out so no no yeah I'm not doing
it it's up I love my daughter you know
what I seen when Hollywood does the kids
oh my god yeah I've seen when living in
this area does the kids I see kids of
successful people how they're raised
tile everything is material but there's
really you know love affection affection
you know I tried like I said I go on the
road every other week quiet and even
then I take like I just cancelled the
week this morning I woke up this morning
said I'm not going see cuz you know yeah
I'm done yeah stay here I'm not gonna go
back to LAX to March enjoy yourself
I for had a Burbank they'll [ __ ]
March now that's it
you know it's hilarious till we're
walking around driving around the area
hollywood west hollywood especially
Larry's and I'm like I haven't seen men
I don't see men out there I see a bunch
of these wither e guys that you know or
hashtag me to and all that and I see gay
dudes like it where are their men I see
a lot of pickup trucks
I see a lot of men they're usually
synonymous with pickup truck maybe if
this hey in the back they're gonna feed
their horses or something but I'm
looking at we passed a bar on the way
here it was called flaming saddles I'm
like boy if that is in a gay bar what a
great name for it where a bar in
Hollywood yeah of course there's a
Hollywood I'm going you never get you
can't mistake and go and go oh [ __ ] I
don't know what this was what you
flaming sad
one thing at the Hollywood then it's
debauchery it's it's a sad situation
yeah
if you look at it from perspective and
I'm very happy I never became one of
those people yeah I want to come out
here and I wanted to succeed in a way
but not to do that at that cost dance at
that cost yeah you know having to go to
premieres and talk to people who you
would not talk to on a daily basis in
any of your [ __ ] lives yeah you know
to dress a certain way to act a certain
way to have that certain you know
vocabulary you know you watching narcos
it's really funny I watched a couple
episodes when I start I was then she
goes no matter how much money I spend
you never gonna be one of them right and
once you know that going in and makes
your life a lot easier that way what you
wanted to do what you're not willing to
do Anthony if it you know I like you but
if it means me only a stupid [ __ ]
movie that's you really right right
won't you rather have one of your
friends come up to you and say Anthony
that's the biggest piece of [ __ ] right
sincere honest a life right you're not
gonna get that here now that goes and it
goes through the parents this is why I
want to get my child out of here yeah
let's be happy I don't fall far from the
tree
I see the five o'clock class at karate
and I see the girls a little oh my god I
love your blouse who loves your blouse I
love your blouse I love your shoes shut
the [ __ ] up every I would walk converse
that's it I don't love your shoes I got
the same [ __ ] one they company the
white or black that said not gonna be
navy blue with a - a yellow idea
it's amazing what has happened yeah and
we've witnessed it especially everything
I like I said to you every time I go
back to New York it takes to read like I
went limitless to read a decompress a
hey it settles it yep you know to think
that Jacob Javits
was this discussed New York was just
look at the old videos of New York I I
love watching them and I love that
yeah iced remember living on 88th Street
and like everyone so while a rat would
get like insomnia that would come out of
the daytime I felt bad for that rat
place it down the street we would hit
him a bastard run over it with a bicycle
and then at the end light him on fire
Oh cry oh wait we did everything that I
[ __ ] him rat we'd beat him he'd be
half mortified we hit him with sticks
rocks we'd run over with a bicycle a
thousand times until we heard a crunch
okay with him on fire to make sure he
shouldn't come out he was should they
come out ma'am you drive on those
streets now there's no kids in those
streets
no that's just it I don't know where
they were I when I went to New York this
last time we took the long ride home one
night I was like wow my neighborhood
looks like and in my neighborhood they
got cameras oh yeah everywhere
everywhere my able to Jersey if me you
mean up on the corner within six minutes
yeah yeah that's yeah there's cameras in
Manhattan your walk around Manhattan
you're not you're never off camera you
are constantly on a camera somewhere and
then with the stuff that most people
don't know about the facial recognition
scanners your plate scanners when you
drive into New York City your plate is
automatically red and everything's run
they there's a record of everywhere
you've been everything you do and I love
how uh like early our memory easy past
when I first came out everybody's like
oh this is [ __ ] awesome I don't have
to wait on that long line pitch the
change in and you're like oh it's
convenient I like that and then you read
the first story about a guy getting a
divorce
and they used e-zpass records to see
where he was going to his girlfriend's
house and whatnot you're like oh oh so
they could use this so they present you
something as a convenience like it'll
always whatever [ __ ] you over is
presented as a convenience like Alexa
that thing you're talking about you put
it in your house
and it's not a magical you know all the
answers aren't in there when you talk it
goes somewhere and then it comes from
somewhere else and then it talks so
everything you say is on record
somewhere to be used after it's
subpoenaed for a
a sword itself example hole right there
there they want me to give to you and it
sounds paranoid you are but they're
watching you I can't be paranoid I
haven't looked out a window I I II can't
be paranoid I know true always but it's
always presented as a convenience and
that's what [ __ ] you listen when you go
on a plane till this day I think those
mirrors are too way oh you think I
wouldn't why not you have an investment
in that point well there's some reason
they're strapping a bomb on tonight
that's true end up end that yeah yeah
you're a fan you know miss Vegas I know
for a fact one of the girls I graduated
high school when went to Vegas for a
honeymoon 85 in 92 they went to the
Poconos like everybody does from Jersey
for their anniversary they put the porno
on and it was then [ __ ] on there oh
Jesus their wedding night in Vegas they
sued the [ __ ] whatever for three
million dollars or something like that
no no I don't trust nobody I don't have
a casino
they got champagne yeah yeah but have
you hit the [ __ ] jack slot they call
up the about you now you have to assume
yeah yeah you have to assume in today's
world all that [ __ ] you're being watched
everything and you are awful front of
the computer and you got a finger up
your ass
somebody's watch these I was whacking
off to you without looking at you yeah
look at this
what about that new Facebook camera that
follows you around the room and all
those commercials yeah they look great
it shows them like oh we can the fall we
can walk you watch you as you're cooking
and this is a good thing like they
present it like a good thing it's like
now I don't think so I think it's a
business I don't touch look yeah yeah
mind your business I'm very happy what I
got I don't need to [ __ ] touch
another thing on Facebook another button
that thing I want to talk to every day
somebody wants to be my friend on
message you listen you got a better
chance of getting raped by 10 then
[ __ ] be my friend not message I want
to talk to nobody
if you have my number go [ __ ] yourself
yeah I see a number come up I don't pick
it up now I don't pick it up I see a
number come up I don't pick up a pen and
none and it better be a pretty name
[ __ ] crap text messages I gave
up like if you text me it don't have a
llama bill attached to it I don't get it
I don't get it simple have a yardstick
pop out so how do people get in touch
you better call me [ __ ] smokes and
the name better come up Morse code
whatever the [ __ ] you got what do you
got going on brother you got showed how
you do the show every day I do it Monday
through Thursday because I was like I
want a three-day weekend and I'm the
boss so [ __ ] I gave myself a
three-day weekend permanently who's your
co-host Dave Landau he's a young comic
out of Detroit and just a funny [ __ ]
guy and he just he knows the show he
knows how to be a good co-host he's
[ __ ] just a really funny guy with a
machete we have Mike on every so often
something my luck he's fantastic to do
comedy with Mike back in 93 oh my god
New York Comedy Club they used to have a
joke I work at the bakery I'm in charge
of the read I'm in charge of the Todd's
all of his jokes
I love the methylation that's Allah he's
a funny guy man [ __ ] holy yeah yeah
and I never dated me back then but he
said that joking but that's a great work
in a bakery they put me in charge of the
tarts yeah he's a good [ __ ] man yeah we
just haven't having a good time it's
it's all about freedom of speech which
you know I'm a 100% absolutist with
freedom of speech
I see I'm a communist I think if some if
someone's offended by something either
don't listen to it or you know do you
want to debate it or you want to discuss
it whatever but to silence people in
this day and age is one of the most
dangerous things you could do I don't
care how repugnant you find people's
speech what they're talking about
because hate speech in and of itself is
this vague term where if you talk to do
different people they'll think it's two
different things
so I am for one hundred percent open
whatever anyone wants to say and then
discuss it so it's not just silencing
people or call and
something in and then ruining their
credibility everyone gets an opportunity
to speak openly and honestly and there
it's not many places you could do that
anymore and things like this personally
doing your own digital broadcast it
gives an opportunity for people to just
say whatever the [ __ ] they want which is
I think gold at this point I can't find
that anyone heat the cop the beautiful
girl over there
that's so stole she'll usually has an
inhalant oh my god she did a hit and she
needed him inhaler right after good my
eyes she was I'm a lot of things good
keep the cop among other things I Berg
the rise kidnapped I sold drugs I did
drugs one thing I can tell you I am NOT
not by a hair in my body because I'll
break it down for you right now is a
racist I'll make fun of Arabians of
course and I had called the Attorney
Blacula before but I will break them
periods in my life where every
nationality has helped me and I've never
forgotten yep that's just a sense of
humor I have and then today as well they
will [ __ ] Court justice you and hang
you for saying something to belittle
look I could never be racist I'm Spanish
I love the word speck I think that's one
of the funniest words I've ever heard of
my life
well I first came from Cuban they called
me a space you know I would laugh my ass
off when I heard all those [ __ ]
sayings growing up you know potatoes or
you know grease balls yeah yeah you'd
laugh you know now it's it's something
and nobody really gets offended no I
didn't realize my last wish I said this
you know was never got food you know
would never raise their hands the poor
Polish people books about these people
not one [ __ ] has ever TV had said
never again right right we're suing uh
because if you got any [ __ ] book
chain they got a book straight books we
never made a submarine with a screen
door yeah the bastards yeah all those
jokes why wasn't the Pope why wasn't
Jesus polish because they couldn't find
three why
you know all those [ __ ] joke you know
all those jokes and that one [ __ ]
[ __ ] cuz it announced and and said no
no half of our generation is born
[ __ ] because of what you people have
done to us you [ __ ] mocked this know
what yeah it's amazing people don't
understand the humor in it like like
under the context of humor and jokes
whether it's stand-up or broadcasting
whatever it is there's a context to
something being funny and being racial
or sexual or so and people want to take
that and lump it in with as if a
politician was giving a speech and and
came out what's a comedy is a different
animal and and if you're doing racial
humor it doesn't mean you're a racist
it's just the way it is we find [ __ ]
hilarious I've done some of the most
repugnant jokes and bits and segments
with Jim Norton it's hilarious we've sat
there talking about Lacey Peterson and
Scott Peterson and he murdered his
pregnant wife and dumped her body in the
ocean
oh you can't you couldn't fathom that
there's something funny to come out of
that but we were playing a tribute song
that some idiot wrote about her and her
baby on the owned a show and me and
Jimmy were laughing so hard at this and
making up our own words that was so
heinous and repugnant and we were crying
laughing now of course you look at the
situation and think there's nothing
funny that could come out of that but in
the proper context I'm sorry there is
you can make jokes about things and race
is the same thing sexuality is the same
thing it doesn't mean you're advocating
beating someone up when you make a joke
about you know the 50s a husband you
know your dinners cold so you've got two
black guys there's just a a part of our
humor that thinks unbelievably heinous
stuff can be funny and to think we can
weed that out because we're so amazing
now in 2018 is [ __ ] funny is funny
the reason why I'm here with you guys is
because I didn't kill myself as a kid I
my mother dead I was 16 years old and
I'm gonna tell you something right
[ __ ] now that would I cracked the
first joke within the first two minutes
of picking up her arm Jesus like I
cracked a joke to myself I leave eiated
the pain yeah I twenty five minutes by
cracking that joke that's what yeah I
left back in the seventh grade the three
years I didn't tell my mother I forged
my report cards I would walk a different
way every day eventually I would have
had to sit my mother down one day and
tell her MA I got left back in the
seventh grade
she was already starting to ask me what
colleges are you looking at all Mike I
guess still had a year - sighs - honey I
was a sob she thought I was a Judy
that's brilliant I went downstairs I
found picked up arm it was purple I
called the cops I said my mom one my
mother's non-responsive well some of
them was I hung up and I've been looking
at it going I knew she'd never find that
I got and I still remember that moment
yeah yeah there was no comedy in mind I
didn't have a dream of being a comic
that's how I relieved that no we doing
it yeah I was talking to a friend of
money drives a cab and we would drove
past a Chinese restaurant we would learn
and - out of this Chinese restaurant is
called - Mike I we would dine and dash
out of this [ __ ] once a month I
had the one bartender we just give him
five blows karate chop it was it's
pennies bartender you gave him a five
and you gonna come in he bend his neck
over you go ha Roddy Chaplin I never
forget one night me and my three
guerrilla buddies with him me Richie
Vanna check this guy Bob Banton Dede
Quintero they could be 17 and they do we
walked in there lathe they knew they had
the zone defense playing against us
thing
- we were gonna eat and run out of there
huh no never because the kids said to me
that they picked me as a cab driver
without Dede Quintero and I had them
picked me up and take me down to the
cemetery to bring flowers to my mother's
friends as a kid he knows the road the
whole thing but we were talking about
the time we ran out of the mic I and how
we hit the front door and the door was
closed and we turned around all the
Chinese were there and Dede had to check
in his hand he threw it up in the end he
goes where's the dishes it was just like
instantly like there was no pour that's
great nothing it was a way to alleviate
the tension all right all right yeah
sometimes something happens and you
write a joke and it's not it's gonna
work for you on stage it's gonna kill
for you but it's also a period joke it's
only gonna work for a certain period
mm-hmm you put it up on to it it's a
great [ __ ] joke and you'll get three
people you know and then I like I
thought I'd tell everybody I want the
two ago didn't November rain was the
number one video they had a billion
views on YouTube well take a look at
they got a billion views but 11 1.1
million people hated those 1.1 billion
[ __ ] jerk-offs I'm saying yeah yeah
we live in this weird contrast right now
but there are there also
one or two people can have an incredibly
influential voice in in your career in
your life like Oh outraged people are
outrageous no no a person was outraged
and they wrote emails and texts to other
people who never would have heard the
original thing that this guy was
outraged about and now they are helping
this one person with their outrage to
tell people to get this guy fired or
suspended or whatever it is and that to
me is [ __ ] despicable and listen megyn
kelly yeah yeah they're gonna give a 30
mil that [ __ ] is gonna have the baddest
podcast do you know a conditioning for
your [ __ ] yeah yeah model for your
[ __ ] if I was making
Kelly I built a ten million dollar
podcast Riley and have everything there
blue face white face green phrase yellow
face I'd have black plays playing the
drum give the [ __ ] you just gave us a
point right is that how you punish her
really by giving her 30 billion girl
poor [ __ ] girl yeah yeah and she
listened whatever she said I wish she
stumbled her words or whatever whatever
the [ __ ] happens you know we just cannot
be that's why I wasn't really I have a
daughter you know I was raised by a
single mother I love women you know but
you know what man if I'm the way out
tonight I grab your ass say something to
me don't tell me 30 years from now I
read them I have a kid but I grabbed
your ass one night in front of [ __ ]
me Anthony you know how he's there you
grabbed my ass and I've had suicidal
thoughts this is really you're still
living is still something come to me and
tell me you know I'm saying cuz it
wasn't the problem boy it was it docked
up like that cannot happen but now means
all of us when you when Richie the cop
was a cop
I'm sure well he was a rookie one day
Hey some [ __ ] Puerto Ricans spin and
Richie or tried to stab Richie and
Richie told you're the cop hey stop the
spec is I'm saying you know grab the
spec he's gonna stab me doesn't mean he
hates picks up the horse but he said
grab the [ __ ] you know whatever it was
respect you know was he was under fire
you know spec shoot whatever it's the
blogs
mucho mucho Boogaloo pills APB out on a
hot
I cannot come out right now Richie's
gonna become mayor after he's retired
from the Queen's Police Department just
come on go you know what with me and
Richie were [ __ ] in 1982 right we made
an arrest and Richie said the word SPECT
really can't do it what makes you think
you could come out and say that against
Rick yeah yeah you haven't I hope you
have an iPhone you know I hope you have
on tape he's gonna look bad yeah top of
that
even if Ritchie said that guess what
Richie's wife is Puerto Rican so even if
he felt that way when he was in 1982 in
1989 he did a sucking through salutes
and a quaalude and when then he had some
Puerto Rican suck his dick and he dumped
that Irish chick with the dirty feet yes
you told the Irish brought a guy that
said this Puerto Rican polished my
helmet for 12 hours straight but people
not all she wants is the grandmother to
move it move the grandfather they all
just look at it like it might as well
happen yesterday I want this person
punished because he did this 20 years
ago [ __ ] half a [ __ ] that rolled in
[ __ ] Pharaoh oh yeah you know when
you see the hip the picture of what's
the matter what's his father's name a
[ __ ] a Woody Allen E Allen and kimchi
yeah what the [ __ ] and sitting there
it's the most disgusting thing yeah yeah
but God forbid so nobody said none for
30 [ __ ] years and that Ronan Farrow
grew up in that [ __ ] disgust that he
grew up in it really is a disgusting
[ __ ] situation yeah definitely but if
it was anybody else they would have
thrown him under the [ __ ] jail now
people getting madder when I was two
ladies a hundred was the one now he's
had a [ __ ] chick suck his dick City
she was 12 he imported a little Chinese
chick that sucked his dick and they all
I'm the bad one they put me in jail for
kidnapping
they all want a movie a role in his next
movie so no one say [ __ ] about him all
those awards shows why don't they get up
there and go and I want to point out
Woody Allen's now they're all full of
[ __ ] I love you brother I'm happy I love
you man fine thank you so much this is
brought Richie the cop which is [ __ ]
awesome
America which I'm laughing my ass off
nice vibe that Studios great you guys
are hilariously funny man I love it we
don't [ __ ] ranks you don't think you
want to promote anything that's going on
just compound media.com that's my my
little network that I got going on
compound
20 if you go to compound Mediacom and
putting compound 20 you get 20% off
Keith makes sure I say that and the book
is available at Barnes & Noble
amazon.com compound Mediacom it's
permanently suspended
is the name of the book that's about it
really excited me is this the last week
unbelievable insane [ __ ] that we've done
in the past yeah twenty or so years
we'll listen man I'm happy you found
that side
thank you man keep the copy the schedule
special eleven o'clock we will you out
in New York ma'am
we'll do it early hell yeah cue very
much for coming on taking the time I
love you brother Cole I love you man
thanks [ __ ] heroes the [ __ ]
awesome we all gotta stick together and
Duke it out you know yeah thanks man all
right and don't forget I want to thank
Anthony come here keep the cop and the
beautiful blondes are coming on the show
today
don't forget this importantly this
sold-out la hoya's sold that I got
December 12th at the temblor Brewing
Company that's right up there beautiful
Bakersfield and then December 27th
through the 30th time at the Oxnard
improv that's all I got the rest of the
year right that's it and that's that
celebrity live but Lebanese live
whatever the [ __ ] it is there's only one
club up there and [ __ ] Oxnard find it
go to levy live.com right now and get
the tickets all right would he bother me
for the show is brought to you by
23andme from now to December 23rd
23andme DNA kits are on sale 23andme to
help you understand where your DNA can
tell you about you and your family's
story it's named for the 23 pairs of
chromosomes that make up your DNA
23andme health and their ancestry
service includes 90 plus personalized
genetic reports that offers DNA insights
on what makes you unique it's easy to do
you simply spit into a tube
providing your 23andme kit register your
sample to your personal trainer and make
it count in a few weeks you receive your
personal online reports for me it was
tremendous I found that I'm up there
from the top of Spain I got a little
West African in me I got a little
American Indian to me I got a little
Jewish to little Chiney everybody's
going to this party
do yourself a favor you need to do this
because of the ancestry composition
report with 23 Emmys
you can explore where your DNA is from
out of 150 regions worldwide learn how
your genes play a role and your
well-being and your lifestyle choices
explore the genetics behind your
appearance and your senses
cilantro taste aversion many people
dislike culantro describing the taste of
Sophie do you have a genetic marker
associated with your version ah ability
to match musical pitches mosquito by
frequencies some people may find they
get more mosquito bites and people
around them like my friend next to me so
what makes some people more attractive
to mosquitoes than others
genetics maybe partly to the blame but
listen with all that aside you want to
find out about yourself go to 23andme it
was a great experience for me and I'm
offering it to you right now now to
December 25th you get a special discount
on 23andme kit order for yourself for a
loved one
your mom your dad your girlfriend your
girlfriend's daddy day I don't care just
order one and get one for yourself cuz
I'll tell you what it's definitely the
way to go
order your DNA kit at 23andme dot-com
slash Church that's 23andme dr. slash
church again that's 23andme dot-com
slash Church I also on it my favorite
okay from the Mexican chocolate protein
powder to the daily packages the new
packages they got with the daily
vitamins I'll tell you what you can't
lose it on it alpha brain I love shrimp
export I love shrimp check immune I love
they got kettlebells they got club bell
I mean they got everything you need you
want to get healthy you want to start
the year off straight this is it start
without for brain why because if you
don't like it they'll give you a
money-back guarantee they only want the
product back who the [ __ ] does that
detain in today's age in society nobody
that's why I trust around it that's why
they sponsored the show since day one
because I believe in on it so gonna calm
right now press in church BAM and get
10% off your order delivered right to
your [ __ ] doors better than you all
right I want to thank 23andme calm
and I'm gonna think on it again plus
Anthony cumbia like flying Jew and your
uncle Joey I see you [ __ ]
Thursday morning I'll see the rest of
you savages up in Portland Thursday
night
tip-top Magoo Felicia Michaels with me
we're gonna [ __ ] burn that town down
get ready to smoke some [ __ ] reefer
Lee kick this [ __ ] meal